welcome to this video
yeah in the last couple of days I've
gotten a couple of requests or questions
regarding the upcoming World
Championship match whether I'm going to
do any coverage of course I will do
coverage have been um yeah not too busy
with covering top-level chess last
couple of weeks and month because I had
some other things on my plate but now I
think I'm going to do the World
Championship match of course because
this is just the highlight of the year
per definition only that I also decided
to do some pre match coverage or some
pre match videos um actually on YouTube
there have been a couple of those videos
already and my original idea to present
the games between Carlsen and Anand that
they have played in regular tournaments
before the match already has been picked
up by Daniel King Grandmaster Denny King
on YouTube so I decided not to do that
just just copy copy his approach I mean
I had the idea independently but he just
started started earlier so if you're
interested to see the games between the
two two players that have been played
them in recent years just go to Danny
Kings channel so what I'm going to do is
some I'll just present to you in the
next three weeks because so the match
will start in three weeks I'm going to
present you a daily video really daily
one with you per day this will be about
20 videos on be exact when actually 20
videos I'm showing 10 games from each
player for 10 games of world champion
vision are the ten games Magnus Carlsen
showing them their chess in their career
showing spectacular games interesting
games and the ideas not so much to to do
a super
tailed analysis but to get to enjoy the
games and sort of whet your appetite for
the upcoming match that will start on
November 9th in India the opening
ceremony I think is on the 7th but the
first game is on the 9th 9th of November
all right let's start with the first
game and I'll start with the world
champion mushi Anand this game was
played in 1997 so already about yeah 16
years ago and you can also see by this
game by the date the game was played the
age difference between the two players
at this time when the game was played
Magnus was just 6 years old and maybe
not thinking about chess and not quite
sure yeah I'm on top Layton with white
against Joelle OTA from France if you
only follow chess for the last couple of
years you might not know this play at
all because he's a retired Grandmaster
from France and back in those days he
was a top 10 top 20 player and I was
very dangerous he had for instance I'm
not quite sure if he maintained a
positive score against Kasparov but he
beat him a couple of times so quite a
dangerous opponent so let's see what
what happened in this demon I'm playing
E for um always been his principal
weapon 1.e4 but for the World
Championship matches so he quite often
played deform against crown again to
power off and it's an open question what
he would do in the upcoming match
against Magnus alright so we have a
center counter Scandinavian defense
which never was some the permanent part
of his opening repertoire usually played
1e5 one of the Sicilian but ok the
center counter Scandinavian always has
been a decent surprise weapon and he
played with a queen d5 Knight c3
attacking the Queen Queen 85
and all this is very normal developing
pieces yellow team plays c6 this some
controls the d5 square and make sure
that the Queen has some possible retreat
for instance of white plays at some
point Bishop d2 the Queen might need
some someplace to go yeah I'm a playing
Bishop c4 developing the bishop and
Bishop to f5 this is some the main line
of this opening with Queen d5 and Queen
a5 and here white has some principle
choice he can play mostly two approaches
are not placed ninety five the other
possible approach let's say the mainline
approach there are certainly other moves
Bishop b2 is the other move intending to
play 95 at the later stage attacking the
Queen and therefore also trying to
address one problem of white setup one
problem is that the knight on c3 is
misplaced it gained this tempo on the
Queen but right now what would very much
prefer to have the knight on some other
square may be here exchange it via d5 or
f6 in order to play also pawn to c3
you'd like to have this this pawn chain
to support the center ok this is the
other main idea but dump like 95 and
this is very direct attacking f7 so
black only has six and no g4 this was
the idea behind 95 quickly starting an
attack on the Kings side so this is
obviously a very aggressive approach h5
is the immediate threat attacking this
Bishop and it doesn't have a very
comfortable Square to go so on black
already needs to be careful what idea
yes be sure to before pinning
and also securing in a way the square
you form and this doesn't seem to be too
great
push up the 294 this looks quite quite
logical at first but White has a very
strong move here this is the f3 it's
quite interesting the main point is that
if a black black capture cm then at the
end that's the sage - loose like this
Bishop is trapped it doesn't have
anywhere to go
so y term just wins this Bishop yeah
maybe for porn but this is the only
slide solace that like is going to get
him should before it doesn't seem to be
too great what Lord she played this meta
he just played 97
the idea is to attack this Knight white
basically as no choice needs to take in
now h5 logical this was the whole idea
we should before the only square so
utilizing the spin and no oops
and now look to h3 this is a very
important point of this early advance
that this rook can be used on the
third-ranked this is much better than
for example f3 after Bishop d5 this
Bishop is not not badly placed and in
case of an exchange it's not so clear
what this really has accomplished gained
some space but it's not very harmonious
okay three is just more aggressive and
it also covers c3 from the third rank so
very useful spot for the rook Bishop g2
yeah maybe this isn't such a great means
at it seems to be an it seems to be
playable but it's probably not the best
the idea is that the normal response
group g3 attacking this this piece is
answered by Bishop d5 which is the
alternative to Bishop g2
return this is the normal move that is
played blackest try to get through to g3
so that later we should be six would it
take it but the problem with all this is
with this move that white can play rupee
three instead of g3 and this was some
foul by Arnaud over the board he
actually had to look at this for his
World Championship match against
Kasparov when he looked at this opening
for black as a surprise weapon and back
then he only had looked at rook g3 but
at the board
he found that rook III is an interesting
idea until you went for that this is an
important quality that you are able to
yeah to really trust your instincts over
the board and not only follow
preparation blindly
okay it's a it's been we're talking
about in 1997 game well of course they
already had computers and so on but it's
not comparable to nowadays still it's
it's a good quality to to trust you over
the board ideas okay
this place is the look against the king
this is one one point and the other
point is well the bishop on g2 is of
course a problematic piece if you I
think about this f3 could trap this
piece and then the game we see that this
is indeed indeed a point like now played
nine to b6 which seems ok Texas this
bishop and the bishop which weeded to d3
this is in fact the thing that the
island needed to calculate precisely
when he played Ruby 3 because of this
move this is what what year played and
it's
just you have the principle choice it
attacks the rook at the text of the
night so at first you think why where
isn't black great here in freshening to
win the exchange of threatening to
threatening to take on c3 or maybe
intensify the pressure along this
diagonal but the white has a very very
strong reply and this is what amount had
calculated f3 this is a very strong move
that idea is has already mentioned
before to trap this Bishop and to the
fun thing is that the piece going on the
hunt is the king king you have to King G
2 this is the idea trapping this and of
course now it gets rather tactical black
needs to calculate precisely and check
how to get enough play in this
complications when the bishop is going
to be trapped if you're doing nothing so
what should like do of course you have
to check the captures the first move to
check would be Knight takes c3 grabbing
the exchange and there we are white
simply recaptures and we see that these
bishops have very good central squares
and yeah there is this threat what
should like do if you if you play a
nothingness like let's just say Bishop
d6 I'm going to play King f2 and then go
into h1 and this Bishop is trapped if he
wouldn't have taken this square with
with the bishop even King g3 and takes
would have been an option and this is
the idea this bishop is a big problem so
what does black guy is supposed to do
here
there's one move you shouldn't miss in
your calculations
maybe you spotted it this is by far the
most dangerous move and this is Bishop
to e3 very important motif combining
this pin with the with this pawn
attacking the pawn this is very
important and
shouldn't be missed by what I don't have
to had foreseen this I mean this wasn't
played but it's a line that you need to
check here White has a very good reply
something you might overlook Bishop c1
this is the best move just covering this
if you would take then the problems yes
Queen takes c3 and the problem no in
fact not this is you better I just saw
that this is even better so white cannot
take because this check when it's far
too much so Queen d2 and then black can
can play apply any move basically and
it's at least it's it's at least murky
look at this thing
it doesn't have a good good place and
like has a look against two pieces isn't
too clear but Bishop c1 is just stronger
Bishop e3 you should pay three bishop
someone and then again this idea black
can only try to get ya to get some some
lucky play like this check it here black
is not lost that those bishops on a
wide-open board are very very dangerous
I guess white is better it's not so easy
to say how much with white is better so
rook to Knight X III wasn't so great
what about this one this is also
possibility and it seems that this will
act to play would have been would have
been interesting let's say like this ya
need to take with the king because this
was hanging and then let's say long
castles similar to the position before
but it's slightly less coordinated and I
still like white here the bishops are
just very strong and will be even better
soon but it's not entirely clear this is
probably what what black should have
done we turn to the game here what what
did low-tier played not an illogical
move we played Bishop to before but this
seems to lead to big trouble can you
have to just ignoring all this and
attacking okay like rupture and to go
and c3 and what no this rock is hanging
and this look is singing so it's all
rather complicated but I know it has a
good move just rope be warned
the thing is if black can just takes
let's say he takes we still have this
problem he will pick up this bishop and
let's say this form of material balance
is very very bad for black because I
keep this pawn and those are very nicely
placed note he played Queen d4 which is
the best move under the circumstances
until Harmon just took on b7
there's no rush to to take it
in fact I'm taking check causes a
mistake what you can just just take him
and now in this position it's a question
what should play do here but he played
the move look to d8 which covers the
Queen indirectly so there's some also
the idea to play rook d7 at some point
and let me check my notes here what are
the alternatives instead I worked yet he
could have he could have tried to Bishop
to h3 which is maybe no it's the better
move but so
just quite problematic because there's
Luke takes f7 this is a funny idea
exploiting this discovered check
disinfectant is also bad for black like
him try various defenses for example
Knight to f4 I can just I can just take
it so ok 7 what is the relatively best
try but I can try it.take move the Queen
but something like this it's just too
much so what is a strong attack but
let's look at logee's move rook the 8
here and took a bit of time and then
calculated this to the end ready to the
end what what now follows is very very
nice and spectacular sequence of moves
and the great thing is - yeah - to
combine all all ideas that you might
have and this just works like like magic
here so Islands move has six white
threatens to take most others so I'm
legit took it the alternatives also not
particularly great let's say what should
like do you can take 93 maybe this this
is a bit tougher but we would have been
deprived of it we're very nice finish
yeah something like this is just
excellent for white
this bishop is still the problem just
have a look and it is trapped again it's
also very important that those those
bishops are both nicely protected it's
all working like yeah very very
harmonious setup for white so let's
return no cheat took it and yeah no it
gets very nice Allan's next move is the
spectacular really spectacular move you
don't know the game I'd like to
calculate a bit for yourself then you
can also stop across this video now and
try to work it out for yourself the nice
technical puzzle so I'm going to wait
some seconds and then continue so Allen
smooth now was Bishop g6 yeah this is
just just very very nice what are the
lines let's let's have a look the
easiest line is Queen takes t1 just
grabbing the Queen Czech rupee six
finger wait
this is h6 this is y h6 needed to be
played King g8 Bashir said and it's a
very very cute checkmate
you don't even need the rope here it's
just the two bishops and the rook doing
a great job and you really slap this
bizarre Bishop g2 so very nice mate you
cannot take the Queen so what else is
there
yeah like Canon also has this threat
yeah - to fight let's say something like
this check is answered
just with this simple sequence and
there's this threat with meat so black
is completely helpless here this Luke is
saying and you have absolutely no time
to save it so black and has no use to to
avoid complete disaster he needs to play
something that Gucci aids to not get
immediately mated so we're just just
very nice yellow tape played the
relatively best defensive played oops
play Knight to e7 just covering f7 for
the moment and here Allen took a simple
route very strong just exchanged the
Queen and okay no still you have this
Bishop to play against but all kinds of
things lying he played them off group d3
which is which is perfectly aright
there also was the most spectacular move
through p6 but it wasn't strictly
necessary to play to play like this
after group d7 like it's not immediately
mated and hangs all a bit what a plate
and I think is even more elegant rock d3
and okay what is black supposed to do
with this book is subject basically and
you cannot move it somewhere let's say
here because shank b8 so you need to do
need to exchange Bishop takes and now
I'm what is blacks supposed to do
this is singing bishop moves and now
it's just can't be aged and picking up
the rook another ideas if black plays
this for instance
you also can
oops I made a mistake of course the
group d8 was played rook d8 was played
check getting to this position this is
quite similar but now after rook b8
destr night c8 what I was going to show
is if black is playing a move like
Bishop h1 there's this idea there should
be two kuku moves and Bishop f6 and yeah
if you like you can look at this
position a bit and try to identify what
Black's next moves on
he is completely tied up this is deadly
pin and also this Bishop is it's also
trapped so it's a tragic filmic picture
here so very very we had set up for
black he will lose all his pieces
basically so very nice attacking game by
by Anand the combination of moves with
h6 capture and Bishop d6 I think is
exceptionally beautiful you need to spot
this idea that you need to take on h6
with the Bishop which is especially
difficult considering the fact that the
rook on e3 is at the moment blocking
this Bishop so it's not easy - not easy
to find and yeah one of one of the
nicest attacking efforts that are
intense plate in his career it's also he
also thinks this one is one of his
nicest games alright I hope you enjoyed
this first part of this epic I sing
serious for the World Championship match
I'll be back
yeah daily from known for game cellphone
and and and Gaza yeah check back daily
bye